bueno hace ya varios años que yacyretá
ha estado en el centro de varias
polémicas no solo en paraguay también en
argentina por estar rodeada de presuntos
actos de corrupción que ha ocurrido
cuéntenos históricamente con esta
entidad binacional en términos de
corrupción y aquí lo atribuye usted
lo más importante es de la designación
de significativamente corrupto al
vicepresidente velázquez ha sido la
sacudida que ha significado en términos
políticos estamos hablando de la segunda
figura más trascendente del ejecutivo
paraguayo que anteriormente fue fiscal
de marcas en ciudad del este en la
frontera con foz de iguazú en esa triple
frontera siempre tan cuestionada y
siempre tan relacionada a hechos de
corrupción lo que aquí surge como hecho
nuevo es que se suma al del ex
presidente horacio cartes quien era su
socio político cuando el primero de
ellos había sido presidente del paraguay
y lo que genera es una serie de
cuestiones en torno a esa relación que
tiene también de alguna forma con la
entidad binacional yacyretá
calificada como monumento de la
corrupción por el ex presidente carlos
menem y cuyo asesor jurídico era un
socio de la fiscalía de marcas en ciudad
del este del ahora designado como
significativamente corrupto el el
vicepresidente de la república quien
anunció que se apea de su candidatura a
la presidencia de la república por un
movimiento interno de la nr el sector
oficialista y que también lo hará
próximamente la próxima semana dijo esta
mañana de su cargo de vicepresidente de
la república y que representa de qué nos
habla la renuncia del vicepresidente
tanto a su cargo como a su
precandidatura a la presidencia del país
lo que dice de esto del paraguay es que
la ubicación del país como un país muy
altamente corrupto según los índices
anuales de transparencia internacional
tienen que ser moderados desde afuera y
nos dice que el sistema judicial del que
la esposa del vicepresidente velásquez
quien también está prohibida de ingresar
a los eeuu y que tenía el cargo de
fiscal adjunta con permiso está
completamente inficionada por la
corrupción hace unos días se ha
terminado el tercer intento de juicio
político contra la fiscal general del
estado quien tenía una serie de
denuncias tanto contra cartes como
contra otros personeros envueltos en la
corrupción y no había hecho
absolutamente nada esto es un duro golpe
a los problemas de la justicia en el
paraguay y a la falta de de capacidad
institucional para resolver los casos
que generalmente acaban en impunidad en
cuéntenos qué implica para los acusados
esta medida tomada por eeuu además por
supuesto de su prohibición como decíamos
de ingresar al país
en el caso de cartes él había desafiado
la afirmación de los eeuu diciendo de
que iba a trabajar cinco veces más por
su candidatura a la presidencia del
partido colorado comicios que están
previstos para 19 de diciembre próximo y
también su candidato a la presidencia
santiago peña dijo que a nadie le
importa lo que digan los americanos que
las elecciones las llevamos a cabo aquí
los paraguayos hacia adentro en el caso
de velázquez ha sido bastante más
humilde y modesto afirmando que ya no
puede continuar en estas circunstancias
y anunció que se apega de su candidatura
el presidente abdo quien es el fundador
del movimiento afirmó que este fin de
semana buscarán un nombre que lo
sustituya para seguir en campaña
electoral a los comicios internos
previstos para finales de diciembre que
son anteriores a los generales el
próximo 30 de abril 3